[موسيقى]
لم يكن متخيلا ان اليابان ستترك القتال
يوما كان ذلك عندما ضربت قواتها من
ابرلهاربر الامريكي اما 41 من القرن
الماضي تلقت اليابان ضربه موجعه من
الولايات المتحده ثم هزمت في الحرب فتحول
وجه اليابان الخارجي عام 47 وظيفه الماده
التاسعه للدستور التي تحرم على البلاد
امتلاك اسلحه هجوميه ركزت اليابان على
الاقتصاد التكنولوجي وحافظت على علاقات
بعيده عن التوتر مع دول الجوار حتى جاءت
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
ازداد التوتر في العالم اعاده مرحله
الاستقطابات السياسيه والعسكريه دخلت
اليابان في الحلف الغربي وشاركت في
العقوبات على روسيا
75 عاما غابت التعزيزات العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه عن اليابان امتنعت عن امتلاك
اسلحه الهجوميه كم امتنعت عن تطوير اسلحه
النوويه اواخر العام الماضي اقرت الحكومه
اليابانيه تعديلات هي الاكبر من نوعها على
استراتيجيه الدفاع ضمن الاستراتيجيه
الجديده القدره على شان هجوم مضاد ورفع
مستوى الصواريخ ووضع القوات البريه
والبحريه والجويه تحت قياده عسكريه موحده
رغم الحفاظ على علاقات متوازنه مع دول
الجوار خصوصا الصين وكوريا الشماليه
وروسيا خلال العقود الماضيه تحول وجه
اليابان اغتصبوا وثيقه السياسه الدفاعيه
الجديده الجاره الصين بالتحدي الاستراتيجي
غير المسبوق وروسيا بمصدر قلق للامن
القومي الياباني هنا تفتح طوكيو اعينها
على الخوف القادم من الغرب
تطلق كوريا الشماليه صواريخ باليستيا تعبر
الاجواء اليابانيه تعتبر اليابان ذلك
تهديدا وشيكا للمنطقه والعالم في الفتره
نفسها تعلن روسيا نشر انظمه دفاع صاروخيه
على سواحلها الشرقيه تراقب اليابان وفق
مجلس الوزراء ويقلقها اكثر تزامن ذلك مع
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا تبقى الصين اكثر
الجيران اثاره للرعب 90% من اليابانيين
انه يجب الاستعداد لغزو صيني
يعتقدها هؤلاء ان بلادهم ستكون الخطوه
التاليه للصين من كل هذه التخوفات انعطفت
اليابان نحو مزيد من التعزيزات العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه تعلن عن اتفاقيه الدفاع
المشتركا مع بريطانيا تتزامن معها رغبه
كنديه يابانيه في تعزيز التعاون الامريكي
الاتفاقيه مع بريطانيا تسمح للبلدين باشرق
قواتنا على الاراضي كل منهما رغم وجود
قرابه 50,000 جندي على الاراضي اليابانيه
فان الاتفاق الجديد مع بريطانيا ينوع
الاعتماد العسكريه اليابانيه الخارجيه لا
تعارض واشنطن بل ترى ان الطوكيو تمثل راس
الحربه في مواجهه تهديدات الصين وكوريا
الشماليه هكذا تحول وجه اليابان الخارجي
نامت مخالبها ضمن التحالف بعيد يستعد كما
يقول لمواجهه مخاطر التحالف هو الاقرب في
الجغرافيا